now recently I talked to someone on the
phone who was very very very frustrated
juice crying she was protesting because
her husband was losing weight her
friends were losing weight she's eating
healthier than them
and she's not losing the way she said
I'm doing everything right it's not
working I don't understand why it's not
working maybe I need to go back to
another diet maybe I should do this or
do that
she's just very frustrated that she has
to spend so much work with so little
result now when you're evaluating
something like this you need data you
need to get data from the person and
you're comparing what they're doing to
what they should be doing to try to find
out what's going on number one she says
I'm not losing despite having a good
metabolism okay so the next question is
what makes you thinking of a good
metabolism okay and she said well I eat
a lot of food a lot of calories but I
don't gain weight I just can't lose
weight and she's 20 pounds overweight
okay so because she's eating a lot she's
not gaining weight she's thinking she
has a good metabolism now if we just
isolate what her problem is she has a
certain set point okay a certain weight
that she cannot get below no matter what
it doesn't necessarily go up it doesn't
go down your her body just loves to be
at a certain weight what she didn't
realize is what's really behind the set
point so if your focus is on exercising
more or eating less and you don't
understand what's behind this you're not
going to get results what's behind the
set point is very severe insulin
resistance and insulin resistance is a
situation where the insulin is no longer
working anymore and the cells okay won't
let the fuel in because one of the
purposes of insulin is to allow fuel in
the cell okay in nutrition in the cell
if it doesn't go in there anymore your
cells will be starving of fuel they
won't get the nutrients and then extra
fuel that you do consume is being stored
as fat
and what happens as a compensatory thing
the body compensates and makes more and
more and more insulin and the more
insulin you have the more of this set
point you're gonna have and no matter
what you do I don't care if you exercise
six hours a day like the weight just
doesn't barely come off okay it'll just
be stuck at a certain point we'll come
back to this in a bit
next thing keto is not working okay now
it was working for the first two weeks
and then stopped working find out she's
doing a lot of keto bombs with dairy as
the fat in the keto bomb okay we'll talk
about that the second two we'll come
back to that next piece of information
is she is fasting she said but for 12 to
15 hours okay what I told her was that
she needs to be at at least 18 hours to
start fixing instant resistance 18 hours
fasting to really start seeing the
change if you have a bad problem with
insulin resistance or slow metabolism or
this stuck setpoint 18 hours is the
starting point okay if it's less than
that it's it's gonna take too long all
right next piece of information after
the first two weeks when she lost weight
then she got her period for the next two
weeks
she had severe menstrual cycle problems
okay that usually comes from Dairy
when you consume dairy especially if
it's not quality and I'm talking about
grass-fed organic just dairy products
from regular milk
okay it's not grass-fed it's than
organic that's gonna add a lot more
estrogen and other hormones and that's
gonna throw off your cycle okay action
steps number one be very cautious on who
you get advice from you have a friend or
personal trainer or doctor all giving
your data what's happening she's getting
too much data overload she doesn't know
what's the vital stuff the true stuff
versus is the trivial versus the false
and you're just swimming in a sea of
data
and you not sure exactly what to do a
couple things that I mentioned to her is
that you don't ever want to take advice
especially related to weight loss if
that person or expert it has a weight
problem okay it's like going to a
dentist with bad teeth okay you're not
going to get the best information you
want to go to someone who gets amazing
result
not necessarily has a certification okay
a lot of times when you go to Google and
you do research on the first second page
third page you have that all the
credible sites that are first right
they're all medical sites because
they're certified they're more credible
right but I'm looking at the information
it's not very effective it's not gonna
work so if you're trying to do research
or find the truth on the internet
sometimes it's very difficult because
you don't know who to believe credible
is the person who gets the best results
okay right number two I told her a hyper
focus on fixing insulin resistance in
her mind she's like well I can't give up
these keto bombs and dairy because I
can't even think about doing this
long-term because it wouldn't be
enjoyable
I said don't focus on the long-term
healthy eating plan right now we have a
big present time problem we need to fix
this we fix this then we can actually
think about what you should do as a
maintenance or a long-term plan but
don't focus on anything but insulin
resistance so that means you need to
actually do intermittent fasting a lot
longer okay that's the number one thing
number two you need to bring your carbs
down a little lower
apple cider vinegar can really help you
and you need to increase the more fat at
the meal only not between the meal but
do it non-dairy okay because I think
that's what's messing up her cycle but
more fun at the meal will allow her to
go longer within a minute of fasting now
there is a valid point of consuming too
much fat and having your body use the
dietary fat as your ketones and not your
own fat but we're not actually
interested in that at this point we're
interested in fixing insulin resistance
by doing intermittent fasting
longer okay because if we don't do this
we can't fix this and this is way more
important than trying to lose weight at
this point we're trying to fix the
underlying cause of this and to do that
we must do in a minute fasting a lot
longer you cannot fix insulin resistance
normally if you're doing 12 to 15 hours
you have to go a minimum 18 but
preferably 20 or even more okay number
three we want to handle any other
problems than weight other health
problems okay with her it's the cycle if
you have a very severe menstrual cycle
for two weeks that is going to
completely and utterly change your body
chemistry it's going to throw you off
it's gonna make you hungry you're gonna
be irritable you're probably not
sleeping it could be a big barrier okay
so I think just by giving up the dairy
that alone will probably minimize this
greatly other problems maybe you can't
sleep you have sleep apnea or you have a
thyroid problem or you have some
inflammatory condition or autoimmune
problem or you have a digestive problem
I have videos on each one of these I
have quite a few on each one of these
you can start some out and find out what
your weakness is but you need to solve
this other health problem right here
next one non-dairy keto bums okay I
already mentioned that you can do keto
bombs with coconut oil with nuts things
like that okay I also told her this is
very valuable to determine if you have
insulin resistance you want to do this
test called Homa IR a lot of times
doctors don't even know about this test
you just have to find a doctor that does
get this test done it'll tell you how
bad this is so you have the right
estimation of effort to solve this
problem okay but the one factor to know
if you're on the right track or not is
this is your hunger going away
okay less hungry if your hunger is going
away that means your insulin resistance
is improving if you can't go a long
period of time
you can't fast between meals we know you
still have a problem with insulin
resistance so this is your your best
indicator not your weight loss nothing
like that but your hunger and again in
some resistance is a situation where
insulin is not connecting to the cell
it's blocked it's not allowing the fuel
in there so here's your cells are
starving all the time okay and that's
going to make it really hard to do
intermittent fasting all we're trying to
do is switch you from sugar fuel to fat
feel step by step so you're more over
here and once you're over here it's
going to be really easy hunger goes away
you have energy you feel good you
finally lose weight thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos